hello everyone and welcome to today's
webinar
gather receptive microglia selectively
sculpt developing inhibitory circuits
i'm alexis cross of leopards and i'll be
your moderator for today's event
today's educational web seminar is
brought to you by labyrinths
and sponsored by visgen to learn more
about our sponsor
please visit their website at vizgen.com
we encourage you to participate by
submitting as many questions as you want
during the presentation
to do so simply type them into the ask a
question box and click send
and we'll answer as many of your
questions as we have time for at the end
of the presentation
you may also submit any technical issues
here as well if you have trouble seeing
or hearing the presentation
i'd like to now welcome our speakers for
today dr loyd benon
clarman cell observatory broad institute
of harvard and mit
and dr emilia favuzzi harvard medical
school and broad institute of harvard
and mit
i will now turn it over to george
emanuel viz gen co-founder and director
director of technology and partnerships
to begin our presentation
welcome sir
thanks for the introduction and i'm
excited to be here today to set the
stage for our speakers
so this is vizgen's first talk in our
series that provides a forum for some of
our early adopters for bridge and
smurfish platform to present the
research they've been
using this platform to enable but as the
scientists focused on developing new
technologies it's really most exciting
to me to see that
these technologies that we're developing
are actually
working to to lead to real world
scientific
discoveries that we'll hear about a
little bit later today
but before we get too much into the
science i just want to give a brief
introduction
of this gin so just uh briefly
i'll describe both what murphy's
technology is
to set the stage for what you'll hear a
little bit later and also i'll describe
what bisden is doing to help
make murfish technology more accessible
through our scope
solution so at the broadest sense we
consider the next wave of
spatial genomics technologies as really
the next iteration of
not just spatial technologies but
genomics technologies
with bulk sequencing you're able to
count the number of rna transcripts
within a
large tissue block to understand which
genes might be upregulated or down
regulated in different
situations or different drug treatments
and really understand
more about which what each of these
genes is doing
but there you lose two fundamental
components of the biological system
you lose the single cell information
because each individual cell
is responding to its micro environment
expressing a different subset
of the gene so understanding what each
cell
is expressing is really critical to
understand the biology
the second is the spatial information
because these cells aren't just working
in isolated droplets
they're very intricately communicating
with each other
and the surrounding environment and
responding in order to
really best sort of construct this full
biological system
so more recently in the last five to
eight years we've seen the widespread
adoption of single cell sequencing
technologies which get you the single
cell information but then you still lose
the spatial component
but now with spatial genomics with
murphish
technology you're able to perform this
highly multiplex measurement
to measure the number of transcripts
that get you a good
idea of what each cell is doing while
maintaining the single cell
context because of the very high spatial
resolution
and at the same time maintaining the
spatial
component so that's what visgen is
really excited about bringing to
the market but before i go into what the
merscope platform actually looks like
i'll i'll first introduce the murfish
technology this highly multiplex
high resolution spatial genomics
technology so murfish is a technology
that builds upon single molecule fish
in single molecule fish you design
fluorescently labeled probes that
specifically bind to a target transcript
so that when you look at this under a
high resolution fluorescence microscope
each of the targeted rna transcripts
shows up as a diffraction limited spot
in the microscope so then by counting
the number of spots
you can directly quantify the expression
of this gene
across the biological sample so combined
with cell segmentation
for example you can see how this gene
expression varies across different cells
so as with traditional fluorescence
technologies
single molecule fish is just limited to
being able to measure
a few genes at once maybe three or
sometimes five if you're using
all the available colors but there's
tens of thousands of relevant
transcripts within each
biological system so murfish is a
technology that builds upon single
single molecule fish to greatly increase
the multiplexing capacity
so just as a brief introduction we'll
hear more
about more fish and how it's used later
on but murfish
is able to overcome this multiplexing
gene throughput challenge by instead of
reading genes out one at a time
we assign each of them a binary barcode
and then we read out that binary barcode
using sequential rounds of single
molecule fish
so as you see here after we stain the
sample
we were able to stay in the sample in
such a way that
first we're able to read out the first
bit and the binary barcode as shown in
the left
hand side of this image here
all of the genes that were assigned a
barcode that contains a one
for the first position show up as the
single molecule fish spot
while all the genes that were assigned a
barcode that contained the zero and the
first position remain dark
so this reads out the first position and
the barcode
then we can extinguish the signal we
same for the next round and the next
round and next round
and then by the pattern of brightness
and darkness across
this image stack we're able to identify
the gene
at each spatial position across the
sample so this enables the very highly
multiplexed
spatial transcriptomics measurement but
from the way the technology works
there's just a couple advantages
that i want to highlight briefly first
it's the image-based technology so in
order to capture more cells we just move
the x-y stage across larger tissue areas
so in a typical morse scope measurement
we can measure up to a square centimeter
of tissue
capture hundreds of thousands of cells
within vinson we've demonstrated more
fish on a broad variety of different
mouse and human tissues
murfish builds upon single module fish
which in many cases
is considered a gold standard for
quantifying rna abundance and we
maintain that very high sensitivity as
we increase this multiplexing capacity
next murfish is a single molecule
measurement so we have single
molecule resolution across the whole
tissue area that we image
so with this a single molecule
resolution we can really perform
not just single cell level analysis but
also analysis on the intracellular
organization of the transcriptome
and finally with this binary encoding
scheme we have custom
multiplexing capacity where we can very
easily tune the length of the barcode
to target hundreds or thousands of
different genes whereas we'll hear about
later it's even efficient to to use
murfish to
very accurately quantify even smaller
panels of genes
on the order of tens of genes because
the smurfish
encoding scheme provides a lot of error
robustness
to to really guarantee that you're
getting the right results out of the
murfish measurement
but as with any genomics technology it
should be both
very highly quantitative and highly
reproducible so here for this mouse
brain slice
with the murfish measurement we we
measured the full coronal slice and we
can zoom into any region across this
brain slice
and really see exactly where each
transcript is being expressed
so when we compare this to bulk
sequencing we find very good correlation
between murfrees and bulk sequencing
and also when we compare replicate to
replicate we also find
very good correlation even in terms of
absolute copy number
between replicant measurement
okay so to better explain what i mean by
the high detection efficiency or high
efficiency of a murfish measurement
we can best do that in comparison with
what's available on the spatial genomics
market so here we did a matched
measurement between
visgen merscope and this oligo ray-based
platform
so when we compare the copy number
detected with merscope
and the copy number detected in this
match sample with the algorithm platform
we we find that murfish routinely
detects 74 more transcripts
so since transcriptomics is already a
relatively sparse signal
especially at the single cell level for
many transcripts you only detect maybe
10
of some of these functionally relevant
genes and a lot of cells
so for example if we look at this opioid
receptor
delta one gene when we plot out the
expression with murfish we see this very
rich spatial organization
well if we look at the expression with
the oligo array based platform we just
see
a few spots across the oligo grid where
there's just maybe one
or two copies of this transcript that
were detected
so because of these advantages we're
really excited to
start to enable more researchers to run
murfish measurements to
advance their own research so murphish
itself was
originally published in 2015. since then
there's been a number of publications
both from xiaowei zhuang's lab
at harvard but also a number of other
research labs that have applied
murphish to a number of different
biological questions
and there's also a growing number of
institutions that are already using
merfish
so you can see here this doesn't even
include some of the ones that this gen
is enabling such as the road that you'll
hear about
in the talk today so that's murfish
technology but then
we also want to make burfish technology
much more accessible
and we're doing that through merscope
which is this platform solution for
integrated spatial genomics
so merscope is this instrument that
performs the foamer fish measurement so
within the box
on the left there's a microscope and a
flutic system to
perform this iterative imaging
extinguishing and restaining in order to
automate the foamer fish process
so smearscope really combines the
advantages of murfish chemistry
with an automated easy-to-use instrument
and a whole
reagent and software ecosystem
so with that i'd like to turn it over to
our two speakers for the
for the day amelia fubuzi and lauric
benon
who have been working with us as early
adopters of the mursco platform
hope you're excited as i am to hear
about the research that they've been
doing
with our early merscope instrument
hello everyone thank you for that
introduction um
so i'm amelia fawoozi and um i'm really
thankful for the opportunity to
share our work today and uh um let's
jump right into it
so we know that brain circuits are
extremely complex but also
very specific so the overarching
question we're interested in is how does
this
arise during development for example
imagine you ask these two
people to learn a new language who will
learn it faster and
uh better well likely the kid at the top
and uh why because her brain is at
this stage here uh where neurons are
forming
synapses at very high speed and then
this is
followed by a period of synapse pruning
where the brain gets rid of all the
extra connections and as a result of
that the remaining
wiring is more refined and more
efficient
and that's why when a connection is used
repeatedly during development it then
becomes
permanent and so synapse pruning is
needed for
precise brain wiring but what does
regulate pruning uh well several
processes but in the last years
work from many labs has shown that uh
microglia play a critical role in this
process
and microglia are the brain immune cells
and they have this really ramified
morphology and with their processes they
continuously
survey their environment and until
relatively recently it was thought
microglia would just
be there become activated in response to
tissue damage
or infection and essentially clean up
toxins or
that neurons and that's of course still
true but now we know that microbials
will play a number of
non-inflammatory functions during normal
uh brain development including the
regulation of synapse pruning but
when we think about synapses they're not
really like this they are more
like this uh very heterogeneous and
that's true with both
the molecular and the functional
level and the best example of this is
the dichotomy between excitatory
and um inhibitory synapses and so
when we think about the role of
microglia in synapse pruning we really
don't know whether they are
genetic effectors of synapse pruning or
if they can discriminate between
distinct types of
synapses and so in this work we explore
the
hypothesis that functional microbial
diversity has evolved
to ensure pruning of inhibitory versus
excitatory uh synapses
and we can really break this down in
three specific uh questions
first do microglia regulate the
development of the
inhibitory circuits and if that's the
case then what are the
underlying cellular and molecular
mechanisms and third what happens then
at the behavioral level if we
uh disrupt the the interaction and so
like i said at the beginning we didn't
even know whether microbial would
actually regulate the development of the
inhibitory circuits and so we started
using a relatively uh
blunt tool we depleted microglia for the
first two postnatal wiximizer using a
pharmacological strategy
and as you can see here this is very
efficient there's virtually no microglia
left
in the cerebral cortex and that's true
from p4
throughout development until pcc when we
then stop our depletion
protocol and ask what happened to the uh
cortical circuits and we focus on two
types of inhibitory synapses those made
by somewhat starting positive
interneurons that target the dendrites
of excitatory neurons
and for albumin positive synapses that
exert a strong perisomatic parasomatic
inhibition to the focus more on pv
synapses
and then for comparison we also looked
at um excitatory uh
then we did that in the mouse uh
somatosensory cortex
so like i said we started looking at a
pv
synapses and we found that they were
increased in
microglia depleted mice and this
increase could only be detected
after the initial assembly of these
synapses so after
p12 suggesting a role for microglia in
the
maturation or refinement of this assets
rather than really in their uh
formation then we asked whether the
structural increase in synapses was
paralleled by a functional increase in
pv inhibition
and so for that we used optogenetics we
expressed
channel production in pv cells
stimulated them and recorded from
excitatory neurons and we found a higher
response
in microgravity device so
in my introduction i mentioned how
extraordinary brain development is you
know circles
are plastics and learning is really
facilitated but
brain development is also an
exceptionally sensitive time window when
even
sub cooling cells can cause alterations
that will last throughout life
so that's why we asked so what happens
if you let microglia repopulate
uh the brain after p15 will
the synapses catch up and here you can
see that at p30
the depleted brains are essentially
indistinguishable from
the control so microglia do repopulate
the brain
but when we looked at the synapses the
hyperconnectivity
the fat was still there suggesting that
depleting
microglia during development causes
long-lasting defects
in inhibitory synapses
then we also looked at excitatory
synapses for comparison
um and here we're focusing on thalamic
inputs and consistent with previous work
we found that there were also
increase in the
depleted mice both structurally and
functionally using
physiology so if we go back to
our first question we uh we can now say
that when you if you deplete microglia
during development you'll have an
increase in both
excitatory and inhibitory synapses
suggesting that indeed might be are
important for
the development of the inhibitory
circuits but then now we can ask
is this really due to a direct
interaction of microglia with these
synapses so for that we labeled
pv synapses in red using adenine
associated viruses that express
synaposis tomato under the control of a
pv specific
enhancer and we injected this virus in
mice with uh genetically labeled
microglia
and what you can see here is that the
processes of microglia are really
wrapped around these uh synapses like in
these examples
um a subset of these synapses was also
encapsulated within microglia and
colloquialized with
microglial lysosomes suggestive of
engulfment
but perhaps even more interestingly we
found that these contacts
were developmentally regulated so there
was an increase
between p2l and p15 and the
highest number at p15 p17 and then they
decrease the gain
at p30 but of course this is just a
screenshot now we can ask how do these
contacts
last or how long and how what happens
when
synapse is conducted and so to answer
these questions
we um use the same leveling tools that i
just described and did uh in vivo to
photon
imaging of microglia pv synapse
interactions
uh in layer four of the small sensor
cortex and we did that at the peak
contact uh period p1617
and what you can see here is a microglia
that over a period of 30 minutes
really contacts the the majority of the
pv synapses around so first on the left
and at the bottom and so on uh top
and when we do this for several cells
and several animals we can really get an
idea of
what happens uh on average and the first
thing that we noticed was
a bimodal behavior of microglia
so there was a first group of cells that
almost avoided previous and after
contact very few of them
and then a second group of cells that
contacted the majority of
pv synapses around up to 60 70 percent
of them
and we also found that um within the
populations that
the population that conducted less pv
synapses the interactions that did occur
had a significantly shorter duration as
compared to
the interactions within uh the
population that was um
more actively engaged with uh pv
synapses
so then we have so what signal with
different
uh interactions and so for that we um
mined published transcriptional data to
identify
ligand receptor pairs that were
selectively expressed in inhibitory
neurons magnetic size 3 neurons and
microglia
during development and the more the the
the top candidates the with this gaba
gaba b receptor
uh pair and actually this is a strong uh
president
uh in addition to its role as a
neurotransmitter gaba acts as a
periclean signal
to regulate several developmental
processes like progeny for proliferation
neuronal migration
synapse formation and most of these
functions are actually mediated through
gaba-b
receptors on the other side the uh
previous work in the adults had shown
that a subset of microglia
express uh gaba b receptors and
they actually respond to gaba for
instance by changing their uh motility
and so the first thing that we did was
to confirm that fp15 in the summer
sensory cortex uh
um around 20 to 30 percent of microglia
expressed
both gaba-b receptor subunits
and we also found that the pv synapses
were preferentially contacted by
these gaba effective uh microbial
whereas the opposite was true
for excitatory synapses they were
preferentially contracted by
microglia that did not express uh gabap
receptors
so then we uh removed gaba b recessors
from microglia using two distinct crease
driver lines
and uh what we found was that the
knockout uh microglia contacts
significantly fewer pv synapses but when
we
uh looked at the excitatory once we
found that the proportion of excitatory
senses conducted by
gaba binoculars microglia was unchanged
so then we went back to our individual
to photon imaging
experiment and repeated these
experiments in the knockout and
this is the control that i show you with
the bimodal distribution that i showed
you earlier
and when we repeated it in the knockout
we found that the
these interactions were no longer
bi-modal and actually
more closely uh resemble those that
interact less
uh with uh pb synapses so we thought
well it really looks like this
um uh gaba recessive micro here might be
dedicated to
remodel uh inhibitory synapses but
then if that's the case then these
knockout mice should have connectivity
defects they're
somehow similar to what we found when we
completely uh depleted uh microglia
right
and what we found was quite remarkable
so again we looked at pv synapses
in gaba binocular mice and we found that
they were
increased in the knockout both
structurally
and functionally uh using physiology so
what this means is that
removing baby receptors from microglia
phenocopies that effect
on inhibitory synapses that we had seen
when we had completely
depleted microglia but then we looked at
excitatory synapses and here we found no
effect
and so what this means is that removing
obvious receptors from microbial also
decouples that is fat and inhibitory
versus excitatory synapses that we have
seen
in the uh the microglialis mice and so
then
we went on and looked for the molecular
mechanisms
downstream of gaba b receptors in
microbial
and for that we isolated microglia from
the small sensory cortex
of pisitine control and gababino cough
mice
and we did a single cell rna sequencing
and the first thing that we did was to
integrate control
and uh knock out mice and knockout cells
and you can see here that they align
pretty well
this also segregates in eight mixed
clusters
and of course i want to have time to
describe these clusters in the details
but an important message here is that
uh removing wb receptors from microglia
doesn't fundamentally alter
the range of microglial states that can
be
observed in the nocal and so then within
each of these clusters we compared
control and knockout cells uh and
and we found that the cluster where they
were more different was this cluster 4
here
now cluster 4 contains microglia
expressing higher levels of what is
known as
homeostatic microbial core genes uh and
higher levels of pruning genes
so they're more mature microglia that
are more likely to
carry out pruning functions and so then
we looked at the identity of these
differentially expressed
uh genes and we found that they were
broadly involved in pruning and when i
say broadening world improvement what i
mean is that
they really involve classical pruning
genes but also genes involved in
motility migration cell cell adhesion
and phagocytosis and so
it's really not one or two genes that
are altered it's a whole
program that is uh that is different in
this in these knockout cells
but then when we looked at the down
regulated genes
with single cell resolution we found
that they were altered
only in a in a subset of this
microgravity cost
for around 25 percent of them and these
same cells
segregate as a transcriptionally
distinct cluster within
class 4. so the question now is are
these
cells gather recessive microglia and
unfortunately we really couldn't answer
this question
with um single-cell hour single cell
data because
gaba b receptors are expressed at low
levels
in microglia and this is and so we could
really couldn't
um we had an incomplete detection of
gaba receptive microcline this is known
as
dropout events so that's why we started
a wonderful collaboration with
like uh it's gonna speak now and uh
semi-fire the broad institute where we
did
more fish profiling of control and
knockout microglia again fp15 in the
summer sensory cortex
to answer this question now like it's
going to give you a broader
overview and then we'll come back
showing you what we found about that
thank you so once you've decided
that you want to use murphy for your
experiment
what are the steps you need to take
first you need to
put together a list of genes that you
are going to measure in your sample
which i'm showing you here and then uh
because
that list has a lot of genes we don't
want to
image each of these genes separately and
um we're going to multiplex the
experiment that means
that we associate to that list of gains
a code book
such as the one that i'm showing here
which tells you
that any transcript for gabber one is
going to be present
in the image one two six and ten of the
sample
so what that actually means uh when you
do the data acquisition
uh on the scope we have five color
channels
one is used for uh imaging the npi dappy
one is used in green to image uh
fiducial bits that we use to realign the
images during rounds
so that leaves us with three useful
channels for
the data and so if we look back at that
code book we can see
that in imaging round one the images one
and two will show
spots forever one and those but will
also be fluorescent
in the third image of immigrant two not
at all in image one three
and again uh in the image of me
and similar things for all of those
games in that list
so um on top of that we also added a
couple of genes that we measured
with an sm fish design so just one color
one channel at a time for those games
the reason we did that is that those
genes are either
expressed as very low levels such as
gabber two and we wanted to really make
sure that
we would be able to pick them up or some
of those were
very short and we weren't able to fit
enough probes
on them to do more fish i'm going to
explain that in article later
so once you've decided that you want any
transcripts for
ever one to be percent in these images
um what's the next step uh this gently
will design and sell custom libraries of
probes that are
uh going to do that the way that works
is that we have a
library of encoding probes that have
this u-shaped
such as are shown here that are going to
tile
the rma of the transcript we want to see
usually we have at least 20 of these
encoding probes per rna which
allows for our signal nomination
um okay at this point we still have
nothing that is very recent
and the next step is during the
acquisition we are going to be
throwing in the radar probes which
are actually the fluorescent uh probes
and these will anneal on those arms that
are on each side of the
encoding probe so we will first pull
three of these to
acquire the three colors of image round
one then
flow in a two-way buffer that's going to
remove just a plural form here
so that we can then flow in the next
three fluorescent probes
and repeat until we've acquired the
whole code
so doing this uh generates
images such as this one where you can
see
that we have a lot of isolated spots
each of these corresponds to one of the
transcripts
that are supposed to be fluorescent in
round one which is the first column
on the left so it can be either of those
genes
and the way to know which one they are
is to also look at
the image for round two and any spot
that is going to be fluorescent in both
of those images
is either a gene for a transcript of
gamma one
rp2 r12 or uh span three
uh and when you go through all 10 images
that's how you can decode this
multiplex experiment and know which of
these spots
correspond to a transcript of each of
those genes
and to decode this we use a software
also provided by this gen
that is called merlin and that's
what allowed me to generate images such
as the one that is here
where uh it's a binary image and i'm
only putting a pixel
on if merlin decoded that at this
precise location
there was a transcript for jim's
teammate119 here
um a couple more details on that
we use a code book that is humming
waveform in distance four
what that means is that any gene
will be three in four different channels
that's the humming weight four um and
hunting distance four
means that for inside that code book
any two genes will have at least four
bits that will be different
and doing that allows to correct errors
either in the in the chemistry where
some probes just didn't anneal
and made a bit appear negative when it
should be positive for instance
or during decoding how do we do that
for instance if uh we see a spot that
has the sequence shown here
uh this spot is worsened or appears
represent in five different channels
but this thing only has one difference
with the sequence we know represents
everyone
so we are going to say that this spot is
actually
a transcript for gather one and
um because it is then different from at
least
three differences from any other gene in
the code book
that also works for one to zero errors
we have a transcript that shows in these
three uh
different images here this one is also
only one bit different from the sequence
for the other one
so we can say that it is a transcript
forever one because it's also
different from at least three from any
other of those genes
okay so once we have decoded the
transcript we still
need to segment the cells and count each
of the genes within
each of those cells and here i chose to
use what we know of the biology of our
symbols
we know we are only interested in
microglia which means that the cells
we're segmenting are isolated in that
brain
and that they express very specific
genes
so to segment those cells we use
the decoded images for transcripts of
the genes
mem119 and fcrls that are specific to
this microbial
and i diluted dilated those uh spots to
make them bigger
which also makes dense areas
uh merge together into a bigger object
and then i was able to remove small
objects from this image so any isolated
spot here was removed and only the dense
areas
stayed and gave us the shape of those
cells
and once that was done and we had to
count the transcript for everything
in the library that we were measuring
inside those
cells there is one other
technical detail it's we also need to
segment the cells in v
that is very important here because we
are interested in
the level of expression of gaba
receptors in the microbial
and most likely the cells that are
neighboring those
microglia are neurons which express high
levels of this receptor
so what you're looking at here are the
counts for two
cells uh two microzia and
uh we're looking at the tens in each of
the disease
that this micro this cell is found in
so on the left you can see that we have
very low
uh counts for microspecific genes
in the z 0 to 4 or 2
3 and in these 4 5 and 6
we see a much higher term of microbial
specific genes
so from that we concluded that the
microbial is actually in those layers
and when we look at gabber spots you see
that they
are also within those layers so cell one
here is actually a
gaba resistor expressing microbial
whereas if we look at cell number two
here on the right
we see that the cell has is present in
layers zero
one and two where we have high numbers
of spots for microbial specific genes
but if we look at gaba spots we see that
we don't see anything
in layers 0 1 2 3 4
but there are higher levels of gala
receptor transcripts
in the last layer and that most likely
indicates that
this last layer is actually part of a
neural and we don't want to segment this
but in that layer with the microglia
to do that we decided to use a threshold
on
the number of spots for my previous
specific genes
which means that i only counted the
transcripts for all of those genes in
each of the disease if
we found more than five microglia
specific gene
in the z we're looking at
um finally i mentioned that we also
included
some fish genes in there
how do we analyze those this proves to
be
much more difficult uh we have two
options either
count spots for those uh transcripts or
integrate the signal just
on the surface of the cell
so first we try this and the output of
this analysis
actually did not match what we knew of
the biology of those genes
so we restarted and counted the spots
in cells instead so as you can see on
this example image here
even with the same fish probe design we
can still see a lot of spots
that you can actually count in both
cells
and that actually matched much better
the the biology
we know of the sample but in those genes
that we were measuring with sm fish
we also had mitochondrial genes
and obviously those are very clustered
in a very small
space and it's not possible here to
count isolated
transfers so we just uh
haven't done those ends and did an
analyze further
now emilia is going to tell you how she
makes sense
of all of this data
right yes so the next thing we did was
to uh cluster uh these microglia from
the
uh murphy's profiling and actually the
clusters were
not too different from what we had found
with the single cell are in sequence and
in particular if you focus on this
cluster 4 and cluster 4 gg here um
you might recognize this uh gene which i
showed you earlier with the single cell
around e6 so again casa 4 and 4g were
expected microclear that we're
expressing higher levels of homeostatic
microbial core genes and also
higher levels of pruning genes for
example this is
a well-known gene involved improving and
you can see that expression is higher in
both cluster 4 and 4g
but an important difference is that what
does gg mean
as they were microglia expressing
gaba b receptors and this was important
because besides the
expression of gaba b receptor we could
also identify additional genes that
represent the signature of this
microglia actually across different
clusters like this
these cell addition molecules of the
tesla spanning family that were
particularly enriched in gaba-effective
microbial
we also had fashion information so we
could see that gaba recites microglia
where anatomically
interspersed with uh microlasers did not
express kebab receptors
and we also found that uh these gaba
receptors might really uniformly
distributed across cortical layers in
the cerebral cortex
but then we could finally go back to our
initial question
about down regulated genes and sure
enough the same genes that we had seen
were downregulated with a single cell or
an asic
were also downregulated in the knockout
microglia again
pruning genes or genes involved in
chemotaxis or
phagocytosis but now we have an
additional information and what we found
was that these genes were
selectively down regulated in cluster 4
gg
so in gaba receptive microglia from
cluster 4 and not in
a cluster 4 negative
cells and not in other gabares
atmosphere and so
what this really shows is that the
transcriptional changes that we have
observed in gaba b knockout mice indeed
are
uh restricted to uh gaba receptive
microglia or phalaenops
and and then the the last question that
we had
uh with what happens uh if you disrupt
the interaction between microsynapses
at the behavioral level and uh to answer
this question we used
music or motion sequencing that was
developed by
the data lab at uh h harper medical
school
and and mostly it really uh allows
unsupervised analysis of mouse behavior
and is based on the idea that behavior
is composed of specific
um motifs called syllables in music like
a specific type of run or
or a rare and they all come together
following a specific structure to
produce continuous behavior
and so when we looked at the usage of
syllables in uh controlling gaba b
knockout mice we found that the
knockouts down regulate
syllables um associated with different
types of
running or grooming and down regulate
syllables
associated with pausing behavior
we also found that there will be
knockout mice had an increased
locomotor activity suggesting overall
hyperactivity
and finally when we looked at these
state maps where the nodes
are the different syllables and the
edges are the transitions between them
we found that the uh knockout mice down
regulates the majority of the
transitions between syllables so
essentially they
mainly oscillate in this repetitive
running and and grooming
uh so against other confirming the
hyperactivity and repetitive
behavior so to summarize what we show
you um
we have seen that uh during development
gaba
binds to gabap receptors on gaba
receptive
microbial and they they activate a
financial remodeling program increasing
utilities also vision and phagocytosis
and as a result of that the cells
conduct more and more inhibitory
synapses over development
and and that's why if you remove all
microbial like in the depletion
uh you'll have an increase in both
excitatory and inhibitory
synapses but if you only remove gaba-b
receptors from microglia
you will selectively increase inhibitory
synapses
and we've also seen that these defects
will persist throughout the life of the
animal and will ultimately impact
behavior
and so finally i wanted to uh
thank of course a lot of people who
worked on this project uh first
of course michelle and a lot of uh
collaborators in the official lab
uh also our external collaborators best
stevens and uh more recently
like karen and samid were paid coverage
for the
murfish experiments uh bob data and this
postdoc is for the
music behavioral experiments and in
general all the kind people who shared
mice and reagents with us and thank you
and
we're happy to take questions
thank you dr favuzi excuse me dr favouzi
and dr banan for that informative
presentation
we will now start the live q a portion
of the webinar
if you have a question you'd like to ask
please do so now
just click on the ask a question box
located on the far left of your screen
we'll answer as many of your questions
as we have time for
so let's get started our first question
is
how many z planes do you collect and
what is the thickness of the tissue used
thank you for the question um we collect
seven
z planes the tissue is 10 micron thick
and so we collect the plane starting
from the level of the glass
and those planes are spaced by 1.5
micrometer
when occasionally a spot shows the same
identity
into consecutive z planes those spots
are filtered
during analysis to count the transcripts
only once
great thank you so much dr bernan now
moving on to
our next question how many genes
did you probe with uh did you probe four
with the murfish
uh we proved 23 genes um
just because we had a specific list from
the
uh single cell renek but we could have
definitely added more
thank you dr suzy for that answer now
our next question um
let's go to okay here's one for you
this audience member says great
presentation could you please explain
how to analyze
uh the gaba rb2 iso forms and i realized
we have
four different iso forms of gabby arts
b2
and maybe i can start and you know if
george won't plug something i mean that
is a good question we didn't
there's equal but we didn't
differentiate uh
among the different rising forms and our
gamma b probes when we design for a
region that is common uh for life forms
but perhaps
george maybe you can comment on the
strategies that can be implemented to
design isoform specific groups
yeah so i can elaborate a little bit on
the capacity
of murfish to detect isoforms
so so currently if there's enough
sequence difference between the two
splice variants that you want to
detect then we can design murfish probes
uh specifically
targeting that that different sequence
if the
difference in sequence is very small
then it becomes more challenging for us
to identify isoforms but if that is
something that we're working
to improve so that we can even i
identify splice variants with very small
sequence differences
thank you both for that answer and our
next question
in the brain tissue it is hard to
separate the neurals and astrocytes
because these cells have long axon and
dendrites so you mentioned that you can
use this technique for single cell
analysis
how could you recognize the single cell
from those complicated cells
in the case of microglia i was able to
segment more or less the shape of the
cell using the transcript as i explained
but in general when we look at
all those cell types that together in
the same sample
we're segmenting the cell body and we're
actually not looking at
what what is happening in the axons or
dendrites
thank you dr bernard for that answer um
our next question
can you explain the sample preparation
set for murfish
um yes so um well the first step
is to slice tissue and put it on the
coverslip by the way this is also doable
with
uh cells from a cell line that you can
just play it on the coverslip
then uh essentially it's a very basic
cell fixation software mobilization and
then you incubate
with a library of encoding probes so
those are the
uh non-fluorescent probes that
i'm showing here on this schematic
and then to improve the noise to signal
ratio signal-to-noise ratio we clear the
tissue
so one thing that i'm not showing here
is that on top of those probes there is
a polyt capture probe that will
cross-link
the rna to a hydrogel in which we're
embedding the tissue
which then allows us to remove proteins
and lipids to make the images cleaner
and once all that is done the coverslip
is
uh interrelated in a microfluidic
chamber
and the fluorescent probes are floating
one
three at a time and then uh during
the imaging once three probes are
from one imaging round are imaged we
cleave and remove the three or four
that is shown here
okay that answers the question great
thank you so much
our next question did you see any effect
at specific inhibitory synapses after
deleting gaba v receptors from the
microglia
yeah and uh i'm seeing the rest of the
question about ssds and actually i think
that that is a
an excellent question we did look at
different subtypes
and the the the whole scenario is
particularly interesting
because the fed is not specific for
pv synapses we do see a similar effect
on sst synapses
as well but um for instance
the question ends with uh the layer
specificity indeed we do see this effect
in layer four it looks like in
upper layers layer two three uh it's
less clear so there seems to be some
layer specificity
and when the part about the subtypes for
example vip synapses
uh do not seem to be affected so there's
heterogeneity for sure
in the way these the difference that
inhibitory synapses are affected by
microbial
thank you dr favuzi uh we still have
time for a couple more questions but i
do want to remind our audience
any questions that we are unable to get
to today will be answered by our
speakers
via the email address that you provided
at the time of registration
our next question is microglia pruning
of pv
inputs specific to pure medial cell
targets
or also seen at pv inputs onto other
inhibitory cells
that is another very good question
it is specific for the inputs onto
pyramidal cells we didn't see any fat on
pvp synapses which is
particularly interesting because it
suggests that there is also something at
the level of this synapse that is
attracting microglia so
something that we definitely want to
follow up in the future yeah
great question thank you for that
it looks like we've got time for a
couple more questions so how many rounds
of reporter readout probe cycles do you
do for merfish
one of one of the most standard uh
setups in terms of the simplest code
book we can use
has uh 18 bits which we imagine six
imaging round with three bits per round
that allows us to target 140 barcodes
which we used to identify 130 genes
and 10 blanks that are used for quality
checks
so um yes 18 bits so that that is 18
different fluorescent probes
thank you so much dr banan our next
question
is gather the receptor expression in
microglia transient only during the
development
um so this is complex because the b
receptors in microglia have two
different functions and it was shown
previously by the
kathmandu lab that uh gaba b receptor
has also important for the
anti-inflammatory role of gaba and so
the expression itself is not transient
because
in the adult you also have this
additional function also during
development so
we also see some uh evidence of that in
our um
sequencing data and so uh definitely
uh there's changes uh during development
in terms of increasing expression that
happens at
early postnatal stages and then it goes
up
uh but then it stays on probably because
of this additional function
thank you so much and it looks like
we've got time for one more question so
let's find our next question here
how long does the gene have to be
successful for the murfish probe design
yeah so maybe i can elaborate a little
bit on the
murfish probe design so for merfish just
to make sure that we
maintain this very high detection
efficiency that we see with
single molecule fish we do try to tile
multiple probes
to each transcript so that in case one
of the probes doesn't bind
we still have a large fraction of the
remaining probes and we get a bright
enough signal
from that transcript so we typically aim
for
at least 30 target regions
so and then that with the length
considering the length of the target
region
that that brings the minimum length of
the gene to around
700 to 1000 nucleotides
so we are able to design probes for
shorter genes but it's just at the risk
of having
a lower detection efficiency for that
gene
thank you george for that answer i'm so
glad that you could join us for the q a
as well
we want to thank all of our speakers
today dr banan dr farfuzi and george
emanuel from bizgen
for their important research we would
also like to thank the audience for
joining us today and they're submitting
all of their
amazing questions any questions again
that we didn't have
time for will be answered by our
speakers via the contact information
that you provided at the time of
registration
this webinar will be on demand laborats
will alert you via email when it's
available for replay
we encourage you to share that email
with your colleagues who may have missed
today's live event
that's all for now thank you for joining
us and we hope to see you again soon
bye bye everyone